how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some really awesome news today
in regards to Black Adam and it's coming
from the rock himself it has been years
since Black Adam was announced and we
were starting to wonder if it was ever
really going to happen but it is and
it's been confirmed by the rock himself
he posted the official release date as
well as a few lines about the character
today on Instagram and the rock actually
gave us a lot of information about what
to expect from Black Adam he gave us a
lot of information about his character
black Adam so let's break it all down
also if you're new to my channel be sure
to subscribe for DC content and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 all you have to
do is subscribe leave a like and comment
down below
Dwayne the rock Johnson took to
Instagram this morning posting a picture
of him as black Adam and below it says
12 22 21 that means that black Adam will
be here in just a little bit over two
years December 22nd of 2021 he also had
a lot of things to say about the
character and about himself in this post
the caption was the man in black like
most kids growing up I dreamed about
being a superhero having cool
superpowers fighting for what's right
and always protecting the people it all
changed for me when I was 10 years old
and was first introduced to the greatest
superhero of all time Superman as a kid
Superman was the hero I always wanted to
be but a few years into my fantasy I
realized that Superman was the hero I
could never be I was too rebellious too
rambunctious too resistant to convention
and authority despite my troubles I was
still a good kid with a good heart
I just like to do things my way now
years later as a man with the same DNA I
had as a kid
my superhero dreams have come true I'm
honored to join the iconic DC Universe
and it's a true pleasure to become black
Adam
black Adam is blessed by magic with the
powers equal to Superman but the
difference is he doesn't toad to the
mark or walk the line
he's a rebellious one-of-a-kind
superhero who will always do what's
right for the people but he does it in
his way this role is unlike any other
I've ever played in my career and I'm
grateful to the bone we'll all go on
this journey together black Adam 12 22
21 and shout out to Jim Lee and boss
logic for creating this picture of
the rock as black Adam so that actually
gives us a lot of details about Black
Adam because we all expected him to be a
villain now Black Adam is really kind of
an antihero for the most part but a lot
of people thought that he was going to
be a villain in the DC Universe because
he's going to go up against Shazam at
one point in time his story was set up
quite nicely in Shazam when the wizard
talked about a champion who kind of went
rogue and originally everybody thought
that it was because he was evil but now
based on what the rock has said it's not
because he was evil it's just because he
wanted to do things his own way but he
is good like the rock said in his post
he's a rebellious one-of-a-kind
superhero who will always do what's
right for the people but he does it in
his way truth and justice the Black Adam
way so he's in no way going to be evil
it seems like however the way that he
does things may come into conflict with
the way that Shazam does things
especially because Shazam or Billy
Batson is still really just a kid and
Black Adam is probably a full-grown
adult since the wizard said that the
champion was chosen a while ago
production for Black Adam is supposed to
start early next year so only a few
months away until we learned a lot more
about this movie but who is excited
after waiting for so long we finally
have confirmation that Black Adam is
coming in just a little over two years I
can't wait to see the rock as Black Adam
let me know how excited you are in the
comments down below if you enjoyed the
video please give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe for more DC
content and a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof